let's go Sun and sand give more than
four million people work it's tourism
industry is vital for the country now
it's under threat baumanis IES in the
resort town of Acapulco is wondering if
this Easter usually high season it will
instead look like now this is my work my
family depends on it I have a wife and
children who depend on me so I hope they
can control the coronavirus and we have
a good Easter first signs aren't great
some cancellations already Magda and
family are here but plan to cut their
holiday sure we're going back home
tomorrow because we're already nervous
and seeing on the TV that something
could happen and the truth is there's
very few people here other famous
resorts like Cancun Cozumel and Los
Cabos depend on international visitors
especially from the neighboring US but
no cruise ships are coming and flights
are down this Beach and many other parts
of Mexico would usually be full of
tourists come Easter instead this time
around a lot of people are going to be
wondering if their jobs and their means
to provide for their families are going
to be able to survive this Acapulco is
taking measures spraying down buses with
chlorine checking tourists as they're
going to hotels will be it with this
faulty thermometer instructions from
authorities were similarly ineffective
municipal ones or during bars to closed
State ones they're reminding that
restaurant owner Salvador says this is
the last place he wants to be right now
but he's got little choice not almost
morning
también tenemos is it tomorrow we're not
immune either and we're scared too but
someone's got to serve the tourists
because if we don't dive the virus will
die of hunger instead some remain
optimistic that Acapulco warm
temperatures and humidity will offer
protection no the corona virus is not
going to arrive in Acapulco coronavirus
just get to cold climate and
here is too hot he's even got a sales
pitch he have a look at the merchandise
here in Acapulco it's warm come here to
pass your warranty even if its head in
the sand thinking it chimes with the
rest of the city's attitude to hope and
hold out John Holman al-jazeera Acapulco